نشر النجم البرتغالي ولاعب نادي النصر
السعودي كريستيانو رونالدو فيديو عبر
حسابه على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وهو في
طريقه الى الرياض للانضمام الى الفريق
ووجه الاسطوره البرتغاليه رساله الى
جماهير النصر عبر حسابه على انستغرام وهو
في الطائره الخاصه المتجهه الى العاصمه
السعوديه قائلا اراكم قريبا
[موسيقى]
صفقه نادي النصر تاريخيه بدم النجم
البرتغالي اثار التفاعلا وارقاما قياسيا
الصفقه غيرت مفاهيم كثيره فما هي الا
ساعات قليله حتى تضعفت اعداد متابعي نادي
النصر في منصه انستغرام ليظهر في خانه
الملايين وصل ايضا الان النجم البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو الى العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض
الانضمام الى ناديه الجديد نادي النصر
بصفقه التي تمت مؤخرا واعلن عنها ومن
المنتظر ان يكون همم هناك حفل همم في ملعب
نادي النصر حفل ضخم همم سيتحدث فيه همم
كريستيانو رونالدو
لجماهيره في نادي النصر وللجماهير
السعوديه اضافه الى الكثير من التوقعات
بالاجواء الايجابيه وبتداعيات الايجابيه
التي
تسهم هذه الصفقه باحداثها في يتعلق
باستذاب لاعبين اخرين بوضع نادي النصر
بلنجازات التي يمكن ان يحققها اا مع
انضمام كريستيانو رونالدو نحن سنتابع اخر
المعلومات والتفاصيل والصور ان توفرت
لوصول النجم البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو
الى الرياض اذن ولكن نتابع فيما لدينا هذه
الملايين الجديده التي نتحدث عنها على
الانستغرام فقط لنادي النصر والتي تستمر
بازدياد كل ثانيه ليصل حتى قبل ساعتين من
الان تقريبا الى 6.7 مليون متابع ليس
الامر مستغربا فاللاعب يتابعه عبر حسابه
على انستغرام خمس مئه مليون حساب وحصد
صورته مع رئيس نادي النصر على اكثر من
واحد وثلاثين فاصل ثمانيه مليون اعجاب ضمن
اكثر ست صور اعجابا على المنصه في التاريخ
المقاس لقيته خلال يعني خمس دقائق عشر
دقائق
بخصوص الطباعه قال لي بعد ثلاث ايام وانت
عارف الحفله بكره فاضطريت اني اشوف اي محل
ثاني اني اطبع يعطيك الرقم والاسم واطلع
برا ما شاء الله هنا بالنسبه
رونالدو قبل رونالدو مع النصر يعني بس ما
شاء الله هنا سواء الابلكيشن او حتى في
المتجر نفسه الخدمه ما شاء الله يعني
سريعه وكل شيء متوفر يعني موجود حاليا
حتى انا طلبت الاسم لكن قالوا بعد ثلاث
ايام
ومع وصول النجم البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو اذا اا الى العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض مع انضمامه الى نادي النصر بانتظار
الحفل الذي سيقام غدا الاستقبال اللاعب
الاعظم عالميا كما ااا يعرف كما قال النصر
متصدر الدوري السعودي للمحترفين لكره
القدم غدا الثلاثاء طبعا هناك الحدث
المنتظر كما اا وصف وكما قال النصر على
حسابه في تويتر مع الصوره اللاعب
البرتغالي همم
حفل استقبال اللاعب الاعظم عالميا وهذا
الحفل اذا سيتم في ساحه النصر مرسول بارك
همم في همم الساعه 7:00 مساء همم طبعا كان
البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو قد انتقل همم
الى النصر في صفقه تاريخيه همم علما ان
النصر يتصدر الدوري السعودي رصيد 26 نقطه
من 11 مباراه وبفارق واحده عن الشباب الذي
خضع عشر مباريات ونقطتين عن الاتحاد الذي
يملك ايضا مباراه واحده مؤجله طبعا هناك
الكثير من الايجابيات المرتبطه بهذه
الصفقه ولم تتوقف مكاسبها عند النصر بل
استمرت مسجله تقدما لافتا بحسب ارقام
ترانسفير ماركت جاء النادي ضمن افضل 120
ناديا عالميا كقيمه السوقيه ب 79.10 مليون
دولار الاول على صعيد انديه اسيا وافريقيا
لترتفع قيمته بالمجمل باربعه 34% اضف الى
ذلك سهام انتقال رونالدو الى مصر في زياده
عقوده تجاريه والماليه للنادي اذ ستجذب
هذه الصفقه الكبرى كوبريات الشركات
الاقتصاديه والتسويقيه من اجل الاعلام عبر
قميص النصر وملعب الدهون له تاريخ حافل
نقلات النوعيه التسويقيه فمثلا عند
انتقاله الى مانشستر يونايتد صيف 20 21
اصبح قميص رونالدو اسرع مبيعا في تاريخ
الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز مسجلا ارقام
خياليه الامر نفسه سيسعى النصر لتحقيقه في
الملاعب السعوديه مع القميص رقم سبعه
لنجمه الجديد بعض حسابات السعوديين على
مواقع التواصل تحدثت عن بيع قميص رونالدو
مع النصر خلال الساعات فقط بقيمه وصلت من
يوناني ريال
باينه على نادي النصر واتمام بصفقه انتقال
اللاعب البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو الى
النادي العاصميه حتى بدات الانذار تتجه
الى
المتجر الرسمي لنادي النصر وهذا احد
المناظر
لمشجعين فرحين جدا بالحصول على
تيشيرت كريستيانو رونالدو في المتجر
الرسمي الذي تباع فيه
الفانيلات والتيشرتات الخاصه بكريستيانو
رونالدو بالاضافه الى المتجر الرسمي هنالك
متجر الكترونيه بيع في هذا التيشيرت
لكريستيانو رونالدو بدا من صفقه الانتقال
من اعلانها مباشره تم وضع عدد من
الفانيلات الخاصه بكريستيانو رونالدو مع
نادي النصر الا انها نفذ بشكل كامل
فبالتالي يتم الاستعانه
بطريقه اخرى
لتوفير هذا التيشيرت للمشجعين باسرع وقت
ممكن الطريقه الاخرى ان ياتي المشجع
مباشره ويشتري تيشيرت او فانيلا بدون رقم
وبدون اسم اي لاعب بعد ذلك ينتقل الى
المرحله همم الثانيه وهي مرحله الطباعه
وفيها يتواجد عدد من موظفي المتجر الرسمي
ويطبع اسم كريستيانو ورقمه مباشره
ليستلمها المشجع لضافه الى تواجد الموقع
همم الالكتروني الذي تتوفر فيه التيشيرتات
قريبا ولكن حتى الان همم لم يتم توفير عدد
كبير من التيشرتات وهي ليست متوفره حتى
هذه اللحظه الكثير من الجماهير يطالبون
بتوفيرها باقرب همم لحظه وبعده ضخم من همم
الارقام لكي يتسنى لكل محبي ومشجعين
كريستيانو رونالدو الحصول على هذا
التيشيرت وهمم
وشراي مباشره سواء من المتجر الكترونيه
وحتى من متجر النادي
عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه الرياض ااه صعب
انك تحصله يعني انا اخذت اربعه شيرتات
الحين مو واحد خلاص لانك هذا يعتبر شيء
تاريخي انا ابغى اتكلم بالمناسبه على
المتجر الالكتروني بصراحه انا لاحظت كثير
بتويتر انه ما بواحد او اثنين لا فوق
المياه تطلب يدخلون المتجر الكتروني بلا
اجانب واللغه تكون عربيه
متوفر بالمتجر الكتروني فسبقه كبيره
عالميه زي كده يفترض انك وفرت هذا شيء
بالمتجر كان لغه انجليزيه متوفر من زمان
وبرده